bagis nous n'avons pas le temps de
laisser la parole à jean pierre foucault
dans les championnats elle a eu
tellement de mal à vous allez ferme a
dit ravira pas tant de mal à vous déjà
votre candidate venir les gens qui
attendent et je crois qu'il ya un petit
problème à ce qui concerne l'or voulez
vous voilà voilà
moins précis lorsqu'il ya bien ce soir
c'est que c'est directement du
producteur au consommateur je paye
directement en cause y est vous mesdames
un mois ne pas prononcer et c'est à jean
pierre foucault de vous poser les
questions
jean-pierre avant toute chose je
voudrais remercier des charmantes
hôtesses de l'air qui m'ont permis
d'arriver là intacte bonjour madame quel
est votre nom gabrielle je suis là on
voyait spécialement par le ministre de
la communication pour préparer la
quatrième chaîne
je pense que vous allez pouvoir répondre
à mes questions la petite enquête que je
vais faire alors qu'elle n'est lequel
quels sont les genres d'émissions que
vous préférez généralement la télévision
madame il fallait dire je le mot jeu
était prohibé ce soir et bien maintenant
on va continuer avec une deuxième
candidate je pense que nous aimons
ordination prénom josiane josiane à tous
via méfiez vous il est dangereux c'est
avec elle qu'il est mondialisé de l'air
je suis envoyé spécialement par le
ministre de l'économie aujourd'hui pour
faire un petit test auprès de la
population de fréjus
en ce qui concerne notamment le calcul
mental entre nous est-ce que vous étiez
très doué en place en calcul mental pas
du tout pas de préférence
est-ce que vous avez des enfants j'en ai
deux oui il signa song qui agace
maintien pas facile
3 on va continuer deux fois 5 pour voir
si vous êtes doué 8 la ville c'est pas
mal du tout 3 x 7 14
car quand c'est bien 5 x 4 23 23 bravo
je ne sais pas maître capello en fait je
devais vous faire dire 20 mai à la main
prononcer fin elle a gagné il a gagné je
ne vais pas la gagne elle a gagné c'est
maître capello qui vous donnera les 50
francs madame est bien la réaction est
belle aussi